all right my little jaw sweet tea oh my
gosh
[Music]
hi welcome back to chasing our roots i'm
vanessa we're gonna be hanging out at
honey's kettle fried chicken here in los
angeles we call ourselves a truly
authentic all-american restaurant i'm
talking about fried chicken and mashed
potatoes apple pie and fresh cut peach
pie and then we've done a twist on that
we've added a lot of products to it like
hot cakes and chicken we're making
honey's kettle home style smashed garlic
chicken that sounds amazing well we're
gonna have a combination of a nutty
texture and we're gonna have like sesame
seeds bread crumbs in it but then we're
gonna put some unique spices like
allspice all right chef well i cannot
wait to try all these flavors that you
have brought for us let's get cooking
all right let's start with our cake
flour cake flour is a little bit of a
richer flour so it gives more of a
pastry taste then i'm gonna add yellow
cornmeal plain bread crumb then i'm
gonna add some garlic powder onion
powder and then my sesame seeds
coriander seeds they add to the
nuttiness and when you pop one in your
mouth it doesn't give you the taste of
jalapeno but it does give you a spicy
taste you know color is one of the main
things about food is that if you can
look at something and it has a beautiful
color then more than likely it's going
to taste well i'm going to put my ground
marjoram in it kind of enhances the
taste of the chicken i have some sage
some allspice and some cayenne pepper we
bring in 100
all natural honey they pour it on their
salads they dip their french fries in it
pour it on their chicken so honey is a
main part of who we are you've got this
moist garlic chicken and then you've got
this fluffy buttery biscuit and then you
take their homemade honey and put it on
top of that biscuit perfection and we're
going to whisk this up very important
how you whisk because the longer you mix
the more you get it to blend and you go
whisking from in to out from back to
forth first of all you got to get your
batter to stay on it so what we're going
to do here is create a slurry a slurry
is like a combination of a wet item and
a dry item that you stir together and
for my slurry i'm gonna add the milk
first always liquid first it mixes
better you know i'm gonna put two half a
cups and make one cup and then we're
gonna whisk that up i just want it to be
blended well enough so it's smooth if
it's too thick then it makes the coating
too heavy and you dip in the slurry and
then put it on the batter the dry batter
it helps to hold the batter together as
you're cooking it dip it in our slurry
mix it around like that drain some off
put it in our dry mix and then we'll
coat it one piece at a time you know
once you get used to it you can do a
little faster now we can come on over
here to our pan the unique part of our
product is the way it blisters on the
outside this blistering effect creates
sort of a rice krispies kind of texture
that when you bite into it you go
through this gold coating of breading
and then you get to the moist white
chicken that's below it that combination
in your mouth touches all the umami
flavors that you have i'm gonna dredge
again i'm gonna put a double coating on
get your coating a little bit thicker
okay i'm gonna set my clock i'm gonna
set it for eight minutes we have the
smashed garlic ready but we don't want
to put it in now because it'll burn you
know when you smash a garlic is when the
flavor of the garlic really gets
released so we want to infuse our oil
with throwing in about seven or eight
smashed garlic to help put a finish of
garlic taste all right i'm gonna put a
little bit of mashed potato on the plate
chicken gravy mashed garlic chicken i
like to present to you the smash garlic
chicken mashed potatoes and gravy of
course honey and a honey's biscuit thank
you i'm so excited to try this chicken i
can already see the crispy layers i can
already tell that there's gonna be so
much flavor with every bite thank you so
much
thank you too
alrighty let's get into this
you can immediately taste the garlic as
soon as you bite into the skin and you
get these interesting surprising bursts
of the coriander seed all those flavors
are really coming together
and you can really taste like the slight
sweetness from the honey
this biscuit is so fluffy
and the chicken is so tender it all
melts in your mouth alright ashley come
here come try this girl try a perfect
bite
[Music]
there's a lot of flavor in that like
that's insane yeah it's great that's it
for tasting our roots that's it it's
been a really fun season we've
definitely been eating our hearts out
thank you to all the chefs for teaching
us how to make such amazing food and
thank you to tasty for letting us kind
of yes
eat our hearts out
and uh let us know in the comments where
we where should we go for season two
she's been playing
northeast i think anywhere where i can
bring out my southern accent i'll be
right back okay never mind i'd take the
memphis back and deja's not gonna give
us
season two i hope you enjoyed watching
no no
my biscuit listen you destroyed that
chicken
come on my little child sweet tea oh my
gosh
is
[Music]